- Well, speaking of fighting,
Deon Cole had this to say
about working with you.
(laughter)
- Dion!
- Let me tell you about Idris' ass.
Check this out.
(Kelly and audience laughing)
We practiced for
two weeks straight on this scene, right?
Of how to fight in the fight, right?
Two weeks we get this.
We know it so much, so we like,
"We ain't coming.
We're not coming."
- Yeah.
- We get, first day on
the set, we get there.
All of a sudden they go, "Action."
Bam, hits me in the head.
(applause)
- So what was your memory of that?
- Well, you know-
- Maybe you should have gone
to the rehearsals more or-
- So Deon Cole is a comedian, right?
- Yes.
- But he's such a good actor, right?
And I was like, "This guy's really good."
So boom, I hit him.
But I didn't mean to hit him.
It's just I was so
embroiled in his character
that I was like, "Wow,
you're really upset at me."
Boom.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- No it was a slip, you know,
but it did hit him
(loud pop)
right on his head.
- [Kelly] I mean, I'm just
saying you're not a small dude.
- [Idris] No, I know.
- So, like when you're hitting someone,
you're coming in hot.
- [Idris] Yeah, little Deon no.
- [Kelly] Yeah, it was hilarious.
He was like "He hit me in my face."
(laughter)
I was like "Don't y'all
do like fake moves?"
He goes, "Yeah, we do."
- We do.
We're meant to, we're meant to.
- And his knot just was like, woo.
I was like-
- Kind of a cool wound though.
"Oh, Idris Elba hit me.
I got in a fight."
(Idris laughing)
I'd be like, "You should see him."